what's the difference between having a
big ego and a strong ego as a director
ah
that's a great question well having a
big ego comes from insecurity right
having a strong ego is being confident
in what you're doing but you have to
beat people over the head with it
one thing I said with my latest film is
I'm not trying to beat people over the
head which my film I'm trying to break
their heart with it and it really comes
down to approach but it really
essentially is about it's it's like a
fine line between arrogance and
confidence right and and people know the
difference but the problem is directors
are fed they're fed that ego on set
whether they know what they're doing or
that they don't they're fed that because
people just assume that they know what
they're doing but for me I don't like to
manipulate actors I don't feel I need to
manipulate actors I don't need to cause
havoc between two people to get a
performance because the audience knows
only what I show them right here they
don't know all this they don't need to
know all that so to me confidence is not
even the right word if there was a
better word for confidence I would just
say being able to communicate your
vision in a very clear and concise way
if you know how to do that you don't
need to you know be that guy that that
is flamboyant but a director two
directors one thing an actor to a
director they're never going to call a
director on that you know what I'm
saying
whether he's arrogant or confident
directors never take all that on that on
a professional set everyone assumes that
they're there because they're supposed
to be there so you have this kind of
advantage but where it really starts to
boil down is how you communicate with
the actors and when my crew starts to
engage with what we're shooting and
they're not just doing a job then I know
we have something I always come by the
crew because they see a million things
right they see a million movies they're
on sets a million times so if I see them
engaging I'm watching the actors
performance then I okay well we got
something the crews interested we have
something here you know in their trailer
they're trying to make it
better they're trying to take it just to
make it a little bit better you know but
that is that is essentially it I always
I tell every filmmaker I mean I go
there's three tenants I live by and I
formed them by watching other directors
that that didn't go on to do anything
and one is don't let your ego be bigger
than your career don't make promises you
can't keep
especially the cast and crew and the
last one is when it's all said and done
let her let more be said than done
lead by example you know you can't
especially in the social media age a lot
of people can post anything about any
everyone's a producer everybody's this
that or the other but when you look
beyond it is the work there that's what
I always tell people don't look at the
surface look deeper don't be so fooled
so easily you know you can tell the
people someone asked me recently you
know this guy's a producer and I said if
he's a producer then what is he produced
he's like oh I don't want to ask him
that it's not would be insulting him I
go why is that insulting him I know
you're only insulting him if he doesn't
have anything I go then you know I go I
knew it feels good to have someone go I
want to help you I'm a producer I know
that feels good but don't be fooled by
that just ask them okay what have you
done
I go we get asked that question all the
time well I tell someone I'm a filmmaker
and what have you done well I've done
this this and this where can I watch it
you can watch it here here and here okay
but if Sun says her producer and you go
what have you produced and they get
upset and they get their ego damaged
that's cuz they haven't done anything so
don't be fooled by that what if we took
it a step back and we see the difference
between ego and sort of a strong sense
of self in even wanting to be a
filmmaker well I mean you have to have
there's a certain amount of narcissism
you have to have you know to me is about
controlling that because it and there's
a certain amount of maybe even arrogance
to say I'm gonna make something that
people are gonna care about so you have
to have just a tiny bit of that but more
so than that what I say is it's it's
more of a naivety and I think that
having the naivety doing your first film
is a strength
it's not a weakness because you don't
know what you're up against and that's a
good thing because if you knew that
maybe you would never get started and
maybe that would save you a bunch of
time heartache and money but if this is
what you want to do and you don't have
all don't know what's ahead of you and
you don't know what's what's involved
that will drive you to the end of your
film at least your first film and then
when you get to the end of it you may be
like wow I'm not gonna do that again or
you're gonna be like I can't wait to do
that again you know regardless of where
it goes they went to Sundance or it got
distribution regardless if your attitude
after that is and that was hard as hell
but that was awesome I got to do that
again
then a there's something wrong with you
and be your filmmaker and the go go go
you know and it's okay to have it be
something wrong with you because that's
what it you know it's okay there's like
degrees they say well artists are crazy
or selfish or whatever but there's
degrees it you know it doesn't have to
be totally negative in that sense it
means they want to create something I I
have a balance because like I said I
have a family and and you know I'm one
of the few you know I'm one of the few
people that I know that has a family and
has done both but that's the other
question I get asked is well how do you
do it and you know I'll ask this do you
have a family no do you have a job no
I'm like okay you have no responsibility
you're asking me how to do it
go you go do it I go do you have one of
these and I pop a grab their phone go do
it if you want me to tell you how to
make a million dollars you want me to
tell you how to get into Sundance you
want me tell you how to get in the
theater I don't know how to do those
things I go but the fact that you're
sitting there asking me when you have
time and energy and a cell phone
make something is it going to be great
probably not your first time out but
that's part of it man like you got to do
the crap to get to do some cool stuff
you know I've done seven films not all
of them are great you know and but the
ones that aren't great that was my fault
I did no one's to blame except me on
those ones you know but every one of
them is a learning experience and
everyone feeds the next one
you